i want to start with congratulations
i've seen the first five episodes of
season four and it is fantastic uh fans
are fans are gonna love it um i'm so
curious though
i don't want to do spoilers
how do each of you like to get ready for
the first day of filming of a new season
are you re-watching like the previous
seasons like how what are you exactly
doing
i think the best prep is a table reads
honestly going in
a big like usually we do breakfast and
and everybody's there and we can
reconnect and all that jazz
what has your life been like the past
six months and then uh going into it and
reading the season that you're about to
do and getting that first big relief and
sometimes they just get so
i mean i feel like it's our way of
watching it for the first time it's kind
of our first viewing it's kind of i feel
like we probably get the same vibes that
people do when
when the series premieres so it's our
little taste of that and i think that
propels very nicely into uh the
beginning of a of a period of shooting
um i would say i definitely rewatched
the show and i go through like my little
fanboy moment and i'm like oh my gosh
i'm about to film with these actors and
actresses like i'm so excited
but nah um
i really and then i started listening to
music and then of course the tavern
being with everyone and getting the vibe
back the hawkins you know getting and uh
just getting rolling back in to costumes
and being on set seeing everybody the
smells
the smells yeah it doesn't like have
that like once
how many of you guessed correctly where
season 4 was going when you started
reading the first few scripts
no i didn't guess if anybody guesses
correctly then that's just that's
that's a psychic ability right that's
that's a superpower if you're gonna see
that read that first episode and be like
i think i know where this is going yeah
um do any of you guys read any of the
stranger things uh theories online and
do you do you have a favorite
yeah sadie says she has like five
favorites
i'll see a few here and there
um
especially once the trailer dropped fans
have like crazy fears
um
that doesn't exist
um
yeah you're talking about it but like a
lot of them are wrong are so atrociously
wrong you're just wrong
i think you know as the seasons have
gone go on well as the seas as the shows
drop the seasons have progressed right i
feel like people think about it too much
like every little detail like why is
dustin's head turning to the left
straight is that are they signaling
something
like why is he laying a 90 degree angle
like no no
he's just laying like this
relax it's okay
for all four of you um when you think
back on the four seasons
which scene or sequence ended up being
the real pain in the ass to shoot the
one that you'd like still have nightmare
development
the the there's one in season four yes
yes the hot pack
the hot pack yeah the hot pack i know
what you're saying oh yeah no but we
okay there was this one scene in season
four that we i think had to go it was
like a quick like eighth of a page scene
but we had to
shoot it and like we had to go back to
like four different days yeah
i'll tell you we'll talk about it that
was like
we didn't think it was
for the people in the back
is there a scene or sequence
yes def i think for sure um
honestly uh are we good to where we what
are we like
spoiler-wise nothing oh man
oh boy like i don't know
i can't talk about specific scenes in
season four but there's actually there's
a good there's a good chunk of uh
uh episode one that that took just a
whole night to get done and i remember
it was it was one of those where like
you're up until three and it was just
tiny little inserts over and over again
where it was just like needing a shot of
your hand and they're like but we can
only use your hands so just chill here
and do this in the next four hours so
that was a little tedious
i wish i could be specific
remember like this
with that one thing and it smelled weird
what are you talking about
you remember it was like no i don't
remember what smelled man
it's probably incredibly boring to talk
about the scenes that no one has
[Music]
they're they're they need me to rap so
i'm just gonna say um congrats on the
season it's fantastic you guys were
great have a fantastic day good to see
you again
later
you